[Música]
en Honduras más de 40 personas muertas
en una reyerta y un incendio en un
centro penitenciario de mujeres la
fiscalía informa que la mayoría de
víctimas están calcinadas mientras
avanza el levantamiento de cadáveres
continúa la búsqueda contrarreloj en el
norte del Océano Atlántico Estados
Unidos y Canadá buscan el submarino
turístico que desapareció el domingo
cuando se dirigía a las ruinas del
Titanic la nave con cinco viajeros se
quedaría sin oxígeno en menos de 40
horas
hoy 20 de junio se conmemora el Día
Mundial de los refugiados una jornada
para visibilizar la falta de derechos de
las cerca de 110 millones de personas
que se han visto forzadas a dejar sus
casas de acuerdo con unicef 43 millones
de menores tuvieron que huir de sus
hogares por la fuerza para finales de
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en
Honduras donde Este martes más de 40
personas han muerto en una reyerta y en
un incendio en un centro penitenciario
femenino el portavoz del Ministerio
Público informó a la prensa que la
mayoría de las víctimas están calcinadas
y que la cifra final de fallecidas se
conocerá cuando se levanten todos los
cadáveres ampliaremos esta información a
lo largo de la tarde
pasamos ahora a Colombia donde miles de
personas convocadas por la oposición de
derechas salieron Este martes a las
calles del país para manifestarse en
contra del gobierno del presidente
Gustavo Petro la manifestación se hizo
Llamar la marcha de la mayoría y avanzó
con consignas como no a las Petro
reformas los manifestantes rechazan una
serie de reformas económicas y sociales
presentadas por el ejecutivo Y es que
después de romper sus alianzas en el
gabinete Petro no cuenta con la mayoría
necesaria en el congreso para impulsar
sus reformas laborales de salud y de
pensiones
pasamos ahora al Océano Atlántico porque
ahí distintas agencias de Estados Unidos
y de Canadá buscan a contrarreloj un
submarino turístico con cinco personas a
bordo que desapareció el domingo
mientras se dirigía a las ruinas del
Titanic Este martes a Francia se sumó a
las labores de búsqueda mientras en los
últimos reportes señalan que en el
interior de la nave quedan menos de 40
horas de oxígeno
entonces Antes que nada es una
estimación verdad porque sabemos por los
datos que estábamos usando como Punto de
partida de 96 horas sabemos que en este
punto estamos Aproximadamente en 40 41
horas haremos todo lo que esté a nuestro
alcance para efectuar un rescate
nuevamente dependerá de si el rv
encuentra algo dependerá de lo que
encuentren lo que debe ser qué pasos
deben tomarse a continuación y realmente
Eso es para que los expertos dentro del
Comando unificado le echen un vistazo y
luego decidan Cuál es el mejor curso de
acción
esta búsqueda centra la atención
mediática internacional por eso una
exploradora y amiga de uno de los
tripulantes compartió sus pensamientos
con la agencia routers escuchemos
Bueno estoy nerviosa estoy enferma del
estómago con los nervios estoy
aterrorizada estoy ansiosa no estoy
durmiendo en este momento solo espero
buenas noticias cada segundo cada minuto
se siente como horas y Estamos perdiendo
tiempo Estamos perdiendo la oportunidad
de encontrarlos vivos la última vez que
hablé con amish casualmente escribió que
estaba camino al Titanic y que estaba
esperando la ventana climática perfecta
y yo de una manera Igualmente casual se
lo respondí buena suerte a mish y lo
dejé así porque él siempre estaba
explorando y no consideré que este tipo
de expedición sería tan peligrosa como
resultó ser muy
y previamente desde Nueva York mamen
sala nos explicó Qué factores dificultan
la búsqueda si entre las dificultades
estaría como decías la falta de oxígeno
que se está acabando poco a poco pero
también se enfrentan Pues a la
meteorología al Estado del mar al hecho
de que durante la noche no hay luz o
dificulta las tareas de búsqueda y de un
posible rescate y luego además también
hay que tener en cuenta que estamos
hablando de aguas a muy baja temperatura
en una zona muy remota que se encuentra
a 500 kilómetros de la costa Y eso
también está complicando supone algún
tipo de Reto a la hora de recuperar este
submarino hundido además también no está
confirmado que el sumergible contara con
uno de estos dispositivos auditivos que
avisa a las a los rescatistas de dónde
estaría el submarino Y eso también hace
que todo sea mucho más complicado
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque ahí
por un lado la imagen de Donald Trump
sentado en el banquillo de los acusados
podría llegar antes de lo esperado Y es
que la jueza de instrucción del caso de
los documentos clasificados de Mara lago
ha fijado el 14 de agosto como fecha
provisional para el inicio del juicio
mientras en otras noticias Hunter biden
hijo del actual presidente Joe biden Se
declaró culpable de tres delitos menores
Cristóbal Vázquez no se amplía desde
Washington
los abogados de Hunter entregaron toda
la documentación necesaria para llegar a
este acuerdo legal en el que el hijo del
presidente se declararía culpable por
haber reportado incorrectamente en dos
ocasiones sus declaraciones de impuestos
y también se llegaría a un acuerdo en el
que el Hunter biden aceptaría haber
adquirido un arma pesar de tener
vicios de drogas concretamente de su
adicción a la cocaína en el 2018
adquirido un arma y habría dicho que no
tenía adicción a la cocaína pero después
reveló que sí tenía la adicción esta
arma simplemente había sido adquirida
durante dos semanas sin embargo pues
quiere hacerse responsable según los
abogados de Hunter biden él quiere
hacerse responsable de estos hechos los
abogados también dicen que tras llegar a
este acuerdo legal se limpiaría y
entraría en paz Hunter biden con la
justicia después de estas
investigaciones financieras que
empezaron desde el 2018 al respecto el
expresidente Donald Trump en su red
social dijo que este era una prueba más
que la justicia estaba quebrada en este
país porque este tipo de acuerdos
legales simplemente limpiaban los años
los cientos de años de crímenes y
responsabilidad criminal que tiene la
familia biden por las finanzas y por
haber supuestamente hecho negocios con
grandes conglomerados de empresas
ucranianas y chinas que terminaron
financiando la campaña de Joe biden a la
presidencia por otro lado los
congresistas en la cámara de
representante dijeron que esto
simplemente era una palmada en la mano
de Hunter biden y que su investigación
iba a seguir hasta esclarecer las
finanzas del presidente Joe biden y de
su hijo Hunter biden teniendo en cuenta
que pues este argumento fue usado
repetidamente Por los republicanos en
las últimas elecciones los computadores
de Hunter biden y su relación con
grandes conglomerados económicos
ucranianos y
pasamos a Francia porque en el marco de
dos investigaciones de corrupción la
policía financiera registró varias sedes
relacionadas con la organización de los
Juegos Olímpicos de 2024 nuestra
periodista Erika olavarría nos amplía
desde París
la policía financiera de Francia allá no
hoy los locales del comité que organiza
los Juegos Olímpicos de París 2024 pero
también de solideo la empresa pública
encargada de entregar las licitaciones
de los distintos trabajos y obras de las
instalaciones que serán ocupadas en
estos juegos olímpicos estas
investigaciones y este allanamiento está
autorizado por dos justamente
investigaciones que lleva la policía
financiera una del año 2017 y otra del
año 2021 en que sospecha ambas
instituciones de conflicto de interés de
desvío de fondos públicos favoritismo y
sospecha de favoritismo no es el único
escándalo que rodea estos Juegos
Olímpicos en mayo renunció la presidenta
del comité olímpico o francés por luchas
y guerras internas y hoy también diez
trabajadores extranjeros pero legalmente
instalados en Francia que trabajan en
las obras de los Juegos Olímpicos
denunciaron ante la inspección del
trabajo a los grandes grupos la
construcción por malas condiciones de
trabajo y presión Ellos dicen París no
es mejor que Qatar En referencia al
organizador del mundial
2022 ya desde comienzos de año hemos
escuchado las voces de varios
trabajadores inmigrantes sin
documentación en Francia que se quejan
de las condiciones de trabajo y de las
presiones sufridas por parte de estos
empresarios cambiamos de tema porque hoy
20 de junio se conmemora el Día Mundial
del refugiado y las cifras del
desplazamiento forzado alcanzan niveles
récord en el mundo según registros de la
ONU el número total de refugiados y
desplazados en el mundo se acerca a los
110 millones de esa cifra 35,3 millones
de personas son refugiadas es decir han
cruzado una frontera internacional
mientras que 62,5 millones son
desplazadas internas es decir continúan
dentro de sus países de origen Siria
Ucrania y Afganistán están entre las
nacionalidades que más buscan protección
fuera de sus países Andrés triviño nos
hace un repaso por las zonas más
afectadas
más de 108 millones de personas se
encuentran refugiadas o desplazadas en
el mundo según acnur siendo la violencia
las violaciones a los derechos humanos y
el cambio climático en las causas
principales de estas cifras que marcan
el Día Mundial del refugiado este 20 de
junio Sudán es uno de los puntos
críticos en lo que va de 2023 luego de
más de dos meses de conflicto
hoy hemos cruzado la Barrera del medio
millón de refugiados procedentes de
Sudán desde el inicio del conflicto el
15 de
medio millón de nuevo nuevo refugiados
en África que ya es el continente que
cuenta con tanto refugiados y
desplazados esto es doloroso
pero la ruta que más preocupa es la del
Mediterráneo utilizada por redes de
traficantes de personas que se
aprovechan del desespero de los
migrantes para huir de África como
sucedió el pasado 14 de junio cuando una
embarcación con unos 750 Navegantes
náufrago en aguas griegas
una persona que deje su hogar que deje
su familia que deje sus amigos lo
abandone todo y se ponga en marcha si no
es porque en el lugar de origen la
situación es muy complicada
evidentemente Tenemos que trabajar sobre
sobre el origen sino que hay que
preservar la dignidad de las personas y
para ello no puede ser que las personas
se tengan que poner en manos de mafias
para huir de ese lugar de origen el
campo de refugiados más poblado del
mundo se encuentra en bangladesh se
trata de más de medio millón de
musulmanes de La minoría rojinya que se
encuentran hacinados huyendo de la
represión militar de myanmar luego de
denunciar asesinatos masivos y
violaciones
el 76% de los refugiados llegan a países
de renta media y baja siendo Turquía
Irán y Colombia los que mayor cantidad
de personas acogieron en 2022
mientras que Ucrania registra uno de los
éxodos migratorios más preocupantes
registrando más de 8 millones de
refugiados tan solo en Europa más de 40
multinacionales han anunciado que
contratarán a más de 250.000 refugiados
alrededor del mundo para contribuir con
su bienestar en los lugares de destino
en otras noticias las autoridades de
India iniciaron una investigación a raíz
de la revelaciones de la prensa local
que señalan que 100 personas han muerto
en medio de la ola de calor que
atraviesa el norte del país Juan Pablo
lucumí tiene más detalles
decenas de muertes presuntamente
causadas por el calor alertan a las
autoridades de India en los Estados
Norteños de utapradesh viajar los
directivos de las entidades sanitarias
iniciaron una investigación y
desplegaron planes de emergencia para
evitar más decesos pero Pese a que el
principal llamado a los ciudadanos ha
sido no salir de sus casas muchos
continúan sus labores diarias al aire
libre hace mucho calor desde esta mañana
y la temperatura está alcanzando los 42
a 43 grados centígrados el clima cálido
provoca sudor y la piel se vuelve
pegajosa También tenemos dificultades en
los paseos matutinos antes Veníamos a
las 5 de la mañana y no solía calentar
tanto pero ahora a esa hora parece que
tuviéramos un sol de mediodía
Este martes el Ministerio de salud
reunió a los directivos de su cartera y
dio a conocer el plan de prevención en
el que se incluye el envío de un equipo
con funcionarios de gestión de desastres
y del departamento meteorológico una
orden a los centros de salud para que
den prioridad a los pacientes con
síntomas como fiebre vómito dolor
abdominal o diarrea y para las ucis la
exigencia de tener separadas tres o
cuatro camas para estos pacientes sin
embargo mientras se intenta lidiar con
las fuertes rayos del sol según las
autoridades los peores días Todavía
están por venir algunas partes de hecho
experimentarán una ola de calor cuando
las temperaturas aumenten 45 grados por
encima de lo normal en los próximos días
la ONU ha estimado que el segundo
trimestre del año suele ser el más
caluroso en varios países del continente
asiático el organismo también estimó que
los últimos ocho años han sido los más
calurosos en la historia del planeta con
Europa occidental medio oriente Asia
central y el noreste de África como los
principales afectados
gracias por su atención hasta que las
noticias
[Música]